diabetes coronary disease autoimmune
diseases cancer pretty much all chronic
diseases of the western world are
associated with a gut microbiome that is
unhealthy the good news is we can
actually heal our
[Music]
gut this class is an exploration of the
universe inside you and how your gut
impacts your mind your body and your
life the microb iome is so integrated in
all aspects of Health including mental
health we've realized that things like
moods and behaviors can be dictated by
the microbes in your gut so we want to
nurture
them we actually Harbor more microbes in
our bodies than we have human
cells question is how do you Foster
diversity for Better Health well to me
the answer is fermentation smells so
good kimchi is just this
superfood everyone should know how to
make kombucha because of how simple it
is put your hand on your belly now take
a deep breath in that will change the
habitat of the microbes it's a Mind Body
technique I'm Dr Emon Meer I'm Dr Erica
sonenberg and I'm Dr Justin sonenberg
I'm David zilber and
this is gut health on
masterclass
[Music]